yeah and and setting effectively almost
setting the dogs on us by getting them
to bark at us and yeah
i don't know if these dogs were gonna
bite me or not
[Music]
the whole palestine match has been the
one of the biggest in well british
history uh with
200 000 people attending and we heard on
that day
uh because we was doing our campaign
which we went to golden screen we went
to the general public
um and we thought we'd just stop there
was that in front of the israeli embassy
um and we went there and had engagement
with uh com through the palestinian
protesters
and we came to know that a pro israeli
rally was happening the next day
so what we did is we said okay look
we're not going to go and antagonize
them
or trying to provoke them but we're
going to have our little protest at
where we are
i think that's counter process
counterprocess that's what it is and
this is what happened
so hijab would you remember from that
moment because what i what i remember is
we was obviously shouting free free
palestine allahu akbar and you know
there was a group of people that we did
we don't know that just protesters come
in
and i looked behind me i don't know if
you saw first
but i saw two individuals walking
uh with um i think they had that thing
the skullcap
yeah the the jewish people were yeah and
they had
a flag they had their flags on their
dogs they was really flat yeah
which again i've said it before i have
no problem with the israeli flag being
on the dock because i believe that's
where it belongs
[Laughter]
i didn't really have a problem with that
to be honest some people thought that's
going to provoke us like it'll scare us
i was like well this is
i mean that's the best place it could be
you know you're doing my job for me um
so they were walking and i was like
hold on a second this is a big design
like i was i was thinking to myself
like it was not the thing is they were
when they were tugging on the dogs and
the dogs weren't like they
yeah almost as if i'm thinking are these
guys trying to say that but one of them
is like a japanese akita yeah like
you know what japanese they're quite
dangerous but i know that they were
vicious yeah they obviously talk so i'm
thinking they're walking i'm not
thinking you have to audition
like like come on like and then i see
right behind them and while
he you know i saw a video of joseph
he's a radical zionist by the way he's
an absolute radical zionist who
causes islamists i don't know what that
means by the way yeah okay um he's
someone who hasn't even condemned an
attack that happened in nineteen
forty six six yeah i had a conversation
with him some time ago
and i told him to condemn yeah you know
it's on the record and what is that your
condemnation here i told him to condemn
the 1946 king david a hotel bank i
thought it was
let's test this man's consistency
because this
is universally understood as a terrorist
attack by the oregon right
who are they who are a terrorist
organization okay paramilitary group
jewish
parliament paramilitary group before the
establishment of the state of israel
1946 and they killed 91 or 93 people in
king david hotel a bomb explosion no
they went in with guns they had there
was a whole kind of um
plan and they and they killed civilians
right so it was uh
it was part of their plan and including
british white british we're talking and
not just palestinians yes palestinians
as well but white is british as well
so they saw that as justifiable because
on the grounds of
uh trying to retrieve the land and have
their own separate jewish state and all
that kind of stuff wow so i asked him
whether he
what he thinks of it and all he was
offering with all due respect
is actually no due respect no nobody
respects him at all
so it's justifications he was saying
well they called the they called the
buildings
to call it and the reason why i used
that example was because it was a group
yeah so it's like for like exactly the
same kind of things that you see
al qaeda do it was a group that was seen
as a terrorist organization by
the united states of america by britain
by the u.n et cetera
so once again him using hamas as a
terrorist organization is
frivolous if he doesn't want to use so
if he's being inconsistent
yeah right with the fact that even if
they do call other people terrorist
organizations he wouldn't he wouldn't
condemn them anyways let's look at that
footage
oh
[Applause]
let's go
it's very clear i mean can you imagine
if isis carried out an attack and i was
asked
let alone ask we went and confronted
their very i would say
sympathizers yeah so the thing is our
state
our apologists apologies exactly yeah i
was an apologist exactly for that
so as far as we know we can see the
video footage as well guys is that
um we're standing there and they're
walking to us and i'm thinking wow you
have to order that
walking walking towards us to see what
it is and they're going forward with
their dogs tugging their dogs
like almost to set them like getting
their dogs barking and stuff like that
yeah do you know let me because people
are this is an international audience
right
in the uk you're not allowed to carry
knives you're not allowed to carry guns
yeah it's different in obviously
different countries yes
um you know if you're if you're watching
this from america you might find that
very strange
if you get caught with a knife or a gun
you can go to prison for a very long
time
the most dangerous legal weapon in the
uk is a dock
yes that is the most dangerous legal
weapon you can have yeah
now obviously a dog is not meant to be a
weapon but you can weaponize this door
quite easily and everyone knows that
right
yeah so when you when you're effectively
setting your dog on a group of
protesters that are
protesting against what like and
something antithetical to what you
believe in
that's that's as good as throwing rocks
at me
or yes that's good as anything yeah and
i have every right to damn kill the dog
yeah and
like you said like you said i have a
right damn i will
think about it i'll strangle it yeah
there's a way to
to to to fight a dog and and the truth
of the matter is
if a dog came to us trying to bite us
you know lock jaw
on your neck on your arms on your leg
i'm
not being funny right but i'm not gonna
let this dog kill me
yeah i'm not gonna let a few dogs come
on me yeah you're setting dogs on me
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be the
person i'm just saying that the reason
why i said that out loud
was very important yeah i've given these
guys a warning in front of everybody so
that if the dog does come and attack me
i've warned everyone i've told them look
you do your job or i'm gonna have to
defend myself but have you really done
that
did you go to the police officer and
tell them that you was provoked
yes let's find out okay right so they
probably gone from here basically
i have taken the other element away from
this area
they have gone there's a police shooting
with them and they've been taken away
thank you you were all being held
there was an error of judgment or some
kind of failure of the police hundred
percent uh i will tell you when
i'm not saying they're doing a good job
and i'm with them and i'm protecting
them and i want to help them
and you can see that however when that
when those designers came in with their
stocks
so what we're saying now
so okay it was very clear that you
actually went to the police officer yeah
he actually came to us if you remember
yeah because after this happened and
there's a few things he mentions there
when you see it
he he um he told us that for example you
said you said him that you was provoked
these comments said you was not doing
your job properly or maybe it was a
mishap whatever it may be
and if you notice the the the police
officer says something strange he goes
he says i have taken the other element
away from this area
so yeah this is exactly the point
because if you notice the the israeli
section
right you are not allowed to we do not
have to go into that place because
obviously it could
cause conflict yeah so there had to be
consistency on both sides because with
the counter
demonstration if if they were allowed to
come to our areas
okay and we were not allowed to go to
their areas then there would be a
disparity
in the way that the rules are being
applied yeah so the fact that they came
in
with dogs provoking a group of people
right and with flags yeah and and
setting effectively almost setting the
dogs on us by getting them to bark at us
and
yeah i don't know if these dogs were
gonna bite me or not exactly you know
what you know what's interesting do you
remember we all had to
run there was a commotion happen and we
run to the other side yes and do you
remember
what it was is that they you know these
guys
they were they were continually trying
to come into the area
yeah that's what i'm saying that's why
when the officers said we uh moved away
that um
other elements the element do you
remember when we went to the other side
we run with them yeah
there was a israeli march coming from
the other side
what we tried to actually do is we tried
to get our people to go back into their
area yes in fact there's footage for
that yeah
we can take a look at the footage guys
get back into your area
huh yeah yeah you can see the flag yeah
so you saw their brothers and sisters
that we was actually controlling that
and not only that
we had the israeli protests in front of
us the terrorist state protesters
the baby killer sympathizers in front of
us and then after these dogs came
and this and enjoyed what the hell are
they celebrating no no what they said
they said
the king of as simple as that and then
when the dog
situation happened and joseph came and
ran away like a little coward like a
little dog there was actually three dogs
there was a two dogs and there was
joseph yeah
and when he ran yeah when he ran if you
remember on the right hand side
the police officers had to stop a group
of israeli protesters marching towards
us
that is what the office is talking about
when he said the other element we moved
them away
because they were trying to sandwich us
in you if you remember so you can see
they were outright provoking us
now when the protest ended brothers and
sisters you if you remember
we was marching and we saw a commotion
we went there we saw a group of our
brothers and sisters who were protesting
and what did you say to them
so all in all brothers and sisters what
you see in that footage as well and this
little mini documentary that we did
is what happened on the day and how it
went yeah now not only that for example
it's very clear that for example joseph
is he's a radical
zionist is one of those individuals that
we saw at golden green
some of those individuals who clearly
mocked the
dead bodies of children by scene is this
afghanistan you know
um and walking past and saying they
killed themselves
and not only that this is such an
embarrassment and this is such that the
world is globally seeing
what these zionists about yeah and
what's happened is this label of
anti-semitism is being labeled when
there
is dissent expressed in the united
states against policies of the
israeli government people here are
called anti-semitic
what is your response to that as an
israeli jew well it's a trick we always
use it when from europe somebody is
criticizing israel then we bring up the
holocaust when in this country people
are criticizing israel then there are
anti-semitic now i know what they do
because i used to
ask them to do it i mean when i was in
the mossad and we had a guy
that gave us problems in the u.s and he
was speaking out
and he was talking like like pete talked
once and said
israel is bombing lebanon with cluster
bombs
we say hey who's that guy you know
and of course the campaign starts and
before you know it the guy is labeled
and he's an anti-semite because that's
what we say he is
and joseph and his you know he was going
to make me cry you know if you think
about it
you know we as jews we don't if we can
be safe the uk doesn't feel like a safe
place for jews anymore
what do you mean by safe do you mean we
can be safe by you know your country
your state bombing innocent people
and if we speak out against it against
we become an
anti-semitic so we don't buy that
nonsense yeah we are not buying that
nonsense
and nobody's going to buy it the whole
world can see the oppression that you
guys are doing
and you saw how they twisted the story
to make it seem
as these two and what did joseph said a
few jewish boys who were trying to join
the rally took a wrong turn
we just took a wrong turn we just took
can you imagine if me and you with dogs
went to the other side what would have
happened to us finished
guys that's it i don't know that's all i
have to say is there anything else you
would like to say
that's it guys uh and you saw that the
real picture of what happened
with cameras with footage i was talking
to police officers and not only that
um hijab exactly not only that hijab
his job using certain words that given
reminder about death is when life begins
for us
being twisted guys once again
let the traffic flow now let the traffic
flow
do not provoke violence this
antagonizers they are looking for any
small petty victory to change public
opinion
public opinion has already changed this
is
the most monumentous time in history
where social media and the internet has
effectively changed public opinion if we
do
any small act here it will be blown out
of proportion
and they will use it to hate us and to
escape gold the entire situation in the
course
our actions here have a huge implication
don't get excited if you're excited go
to the gym honestly go to the gym
you're not helping anyone yeah i'll get
married
we'll get the most documentary up over
here
all right guys it's been a pleasure
remember now
the fight is online that is where the
fight is
keep active online don't get excited and
then just let it simmer
no let's continue the pressure
on these organizations and on these
people
we are winning do not spoil it with any
bad behavior so when the protests ended
we saw a group of youngsters going and
carrying on and we said look it's time
to disperse guys
uh inshallah it's and you saw that for
yourself inshallah we're not there
because we know
people like radical zionists like this
uh scumbag
would look for any excuse and you know
what's very interesting
he watches our um video that we did our
campaign and go the screen
and he talks about everything except
what those two individuals said
and he doesn't even at this point he
hasn't even condemned his children being
killed thank you very much unless on the
end of that note somebody not condemning
the killing of innocent children dying
is as good as the one walking by and
saying they killed themself
this joseph and that's why he doesn't
have the face to come to the park you
know
because he he i would say to his face
shame on you and that's what i did i
could see the fear in his eyes that day
yeah you can see on the camera yeah
it was like a little coward yeah he he
had to run away these islamists
call us whatever you like here okay no
problem what is did you watch that
and you are too concerned about going to
golden screen and using our freedom and
speech to have a dialogue with the
designers of the jewish community at
large we don't know all jews
are like you we know all of them are not
like you but we saw a few that would
like you and they make us sick
yeah okay you academic eunuch
brown sisters hope you enjoyed this
video and shall i share this far and
wide so people can see
what really happened on those days when
these so-called zionist radicals took a
wrong left turn you know we made them
take a right right turn